AND  THERE ARE MANY , THAT'S WHM
CONTINUING TO WORK TOWARD.
>>HITO
DON'T WANTSEEE THIS WEEK THAT
YOU WE.
OF STATEAS SENATORN
IF T DEPARTMENT
DECIDES THATENT
CONSEQUENCESING SIDENT AND POTT
ANOTT E DEPARTMENT WILL DO AT T
HOLDING PEOPLE A
CENTRAL TO NATS  P CEN QIO
EV BE TESTIED  H
ING THAT WASSKED
THEM IS SUPPOS
IF Y A, NOU'T
LITY IF ED THE THENCE POIN
THEM HIN S ELSE UROU INVESTER A
SAYING THAT HE SHOULD LID IF, S?
PRESIDAN DHAVE SOMEXCEPTIONS SOE
E FI DO THINK THAT, JUST LIK
ANY AMERICANIF TREEVIDENCE, THA.
BUOW IT ANON'T WAN I
OPN  THAICUSE I DOT
CTD UNLIKEEO
SEEMS W THAT TRE N'T WANT TO DOO
OFAWSHOULD APPLYO ANYONE.
>> SECRETA,
CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXIATEZ GAVE ANV
AND SHE WAS TALKIN
LITTLE GIRL WHAT CSEPEOPLE, E W.
S SHE BELIEVHE
LI COUNTRY TWO TIN TUNES
AT
WELL, I THINKSA
HAVANY PEOPLE SEEM
TOR RESENT WOMENLIEN
MEDIOR ANYTHING ELSE.
ATOMHIO EP
OUI  WL NST ANSP
BENT AT SOME
I CERTY RS OF
E OBSTACLES YO
OVERCOME T
BUT NTINUELL YOUNG
AT IO PURSUE
MEDIA, WITALL  MISOGYNY,S MADE